we have had our fair share of poor PC
launches this year in fact over the last
12 months in fact for all of time to be
honest the latest game that is launched
with pretty poor performance on PC and
also on PS5 I believe is Star Wars Jedi
Survivor I do have to note that I played
it on PS5 you can see my gameplay here
on this channel and I actually did not
have a rough performance I had some
frame rate drops I imagine the same
places that everybody else did but I
didn't have some of the screen tearing
issues or a bunch of other bugs a lot of
other players haven't counted and I
believe that's because I played with HDR
off performance mode off Ray tracing off
and I'm not playing on a very demanding
monitor I don't have a OLED it's very
small or even comments on my video if
you've been like how is your performance
so much better than mine on PS5 and I
think it's just got to be my setup I did
decide to try the PC Port end here's how
that went
so that was already a little bit of lag
there
and again
this definitely is already worse than my
oh
ah and it's so unfortunate oh boy
because this is supposed to be like
a tense intro
to your game and players are immediately
pulled out
man and it's so frequent
I'm gonna see what happens when you
actually getting a gameplay though right
seems okay here
frame drops it looks muddier than it did
on my PS5 oh wow yeah this is bad
damn what a shame
oh there's like a really weird
artifacting going on
damn dude
oh yeah I was not having this on on PS5
so today I wanted to dive in what some
of these problems are how they look
we'll take a look at the digital Foundry
video we'll take a look at what's
actually happening and why this keeps
happening to the first story here Star
Wars Jedi Survivor launched yesterday on
PC and at this point in time it's a
technical failure on just about every
level according to Euro gamer and this
is a really interesting point I remember
saying when full and order just came out
that I felt like it was almost a good
game it just had a ton of bugs and
problems
um and it seems like virtually all of
the same problems also exist for
Survivor in some cases even worse Shader
compilation stutter and travisa started
out back while the in-game options offer
no recourse in addressing the game's key
issues which is actually a really
interesting point where PC is concerned
in terms of Polish performance and
accessibility this is actually far worse
than Fallen order perhaps taking the
cake as the worst AAA PC Board of 2023
despite some remarkably strong
competition and has unfortunately been
kind of a bad year so let's just jump
into the digital Foundry video shall we
I did a reaction to this on Twitch so
let's jump over there
they make such great videos if you
aren't already familiar with digital
Foundry
they explain why things don't work I
highly recommend it
[Music]
nice very good editing Star Wars Jedi
Survivor is here on PC and it is in a
state that is hard to believe it is
doubly hard to believe as its
predecessor Jedi Fallen order launched
with the exact same issues in 2019.
Shader compilation stutter traversal
stutter that still plagues modern PCS
and really poor options which do nothing
to solve the game's core issues I was
stunned the options were really strange
Jedi Survivor is in an even worse State
than that game for one the options are
Bare Bones
ue4 standards even in their naming
essentially there's also zero contacts
given to the user as to what the visual
or performance are for the various
settings that they don't actually
explain what they do this is a huge
issue for the average user to optimize
their experience to their particular PC
furthermore changing settings at times
can negative I also think like that's a
really interesting note because so many
issues that PCS have
um like why PC ports are so hard no
matter who who does it and why they so
often have plagued with issues is really
because there are so many options so not
actually telling people like what does
visual effects mean to your average
player that could mean anything check
out this here where I'm toast processing
what does that mean to the average
person it's a flat 60 FPS vsync with Ray
tracing on I turned it off and well it's
a flat vsync 60fps there too I turn Ray
tracing back on oh it's a wobbly sub 60
FPS all of a sudden I have to restart
the game now for the performance to be
back to normal again this really
shouldn't be the case in a game there
are other issues with the options as
well you only have access to TAA and
fsr2 and both aren't that great but fsr2
in this game is in my opinion not very
good for acceptable image quality
essentially whenever an object moves or
the camera moves in this game fsr2 at
all quality levels causes a blurred
pixelization like you can see I did
notice that yeah this applies to the
entire image and all aspects of it it is
really strange and moving the camera the
Shader pre-compilation in this game
fails to recompile all Shader
combinations so when you play the game
you will see Shader compilation stutter
everywhere you go in Jedi Survivor
moving across the Game World you will
see spikes of frame time over a number
of frames or over a few seconds in total
as you cross invisible boundaries in the
game World this happens all over the
game world no matter what era you are in
Coruscant in the opening areas of Kobo
and especially in the town of Kobo this
will also happening or GPU combination
you have even areas that look innocuous
will have frame time spikes in them the
frame time spikes of these stutters can
be smaller but they can also be large
and they can compound with any Shader
compilation stutter that might
potentially occur at the same time as
that load no matter how many times you
play the game or run across an area you
will always see the same stutter nothing
can prevent this and yes nothing can
prevent this even playing the game at
the lowest settings you will still see
traversal stutter it's really
interesting that even if you play at the
lowest settings possible you're still
going to see frame time stutter wait so
this is what
EA had to say about it let me just
remove my camera for a second
we are aware that Star Wars Jedi
Survivor isn't performing to our
standards for a percentage of our PC
players well it sounds like it's pretty
much all of them in particular those
with high-end machines or certain
specific configurations
for example players using Cutting Edge
multi-threaded chipsets designed for
Windows 11 were encountering problems on
Windows 10. that seems like a cop-out
I'm not a huge fan of of what you've
done here oh no hang on sorry
because this one is EA I do have to do
my um Andrew Wilson voice rest assured
we are working to address these cases
quickly while there is no single
comprehensive solution for PC
performance the team which is true the
team has been working on fixes We
Believe will improve performance across
the spectrum of configurations we are
committed to fixing these issues as soon
as possible but each patch requires
significant testing to ensure that we
don't introduce new problems thanks for
understanding and apologies to any of
our players experiencing these issues we
will continue to monitor performance
across all platforms and share update
timing as soon as it's available so the
good news is it did get its first patch
addressing performance issues the patch
for PC has addressed issues including
performance problems for non-retrace
graphics modes game crashes and bugs
tied to vftx Ai cinematics and more the
PlayStation 5 and Xbox series X consoles
are expected to get the same patches
soon but I just play the PC version even
with the patch and still had
an unfortunate like butt ton of frame
rate drops as seen earlier in this video
so
to the questions that I asked some
friends in Dev
um the first one and I got such an
interesting answer to this was why do
games release with performance problems
even if they have multi-million dollar
budgets this is something that I've seen
around Twitter or on Reddit
where the consensus seems to be this
company has so much money why is that
game buggy they have so much money to
fix all of these problems why do they
keep having bugs why can't you just
throw money at the problem
um and if you've never worked in game
development I actually don't think that
that's that unreasonable of a question I
understand where it's coming from the
reality is that it's sort of the
opposite like the more money that is
involved in the project the bigger the
scale the hotter it is not the other way
around you actually can't just throw
money
at
video games to fix problems it kind of
doesn't work that way you could even add
more stuff and think that that would
solve the problem faster but it can't
because nobody can really have all
information needed in their brain of the
exact current state of the game at all
times and the more people you have the
less synchronicity there is among the
team so it like I said kind of gets
hotter does that make sense I'll read
the answer that Christina gave me here
she's a friend who works in AAA
development I'll leave a link to her
Twitter below if you want to check her
out she said I have to address the
subtle implication that budget is a
preventer of problems the hardest part
of video games is not any technical
problem it is getting hundreds or
thousands of people to do just the right
work at just the right time and somehow
all finish on the right day in time for
launch larger budgets mean more problems
and more complexity no single person has
to say to the game in the head no one
can and so for a triple A game you're
relying on shades of chains and chains
of chains of reporting and coordination
to bring everything all together thus
you understand complexity and the larger
investment in the game the more you need
to recoup it that means marketing spends
ad campaigns buys from Russian physical
replacement all organized months if not
years in advance and let's be realistic
those dates of guesses estimates if
you're being generous targets if you're
being realistic so while all of that
money is being spent on marketing way
before the team even knows how the game
is doing that's a cost that would be
lost if the date shifts and the more and
more complex the game gets as
development goes on the more difficult
it is for any one person who has
anything to do with the team to
understand the exact current state of
the game at any given time while people
are constantly updating and iterating on
it every single day basically the more
money actually the more complicated it
gets the more difficult it gets second
question I asked is why aren't AAA game
developers able to catch these issues
like how are they not fixed before
launch I'm sure most of you are already
aware of a stance I've shared many a
time which is that in a lot of cases
they are it's just that the publisher
needed the game to come out at that time
and that is certainly the case for EA
who runs on the stock market this is not
a quote from a game deaf friend this is
the thing that I have said for many a
year after after I interviewed it was
like 50 plus devs a while back about
games and release dates and and I got so
much interesting information and why ear
particularly concerned they have a
history of doing this release dates on
actually for the public they're not for
gamers there for the stock market so
when they've said hey this game's coming
out at this date it can't move because
they've told these people these
shareholders who are you know running
stocks or whatever it is Big stock
people do that they would get money back
for the money spent on this particular
date they kind of can't move it the
stock market doesn't necessarily care
about the quality of the game it cares
about sales and time and time again even
at games of poor quality games will
still buy them which is a whole problem
in and of itself and it's a disgusting
part of the industry in my opinion but
that's one facet is that it's not up to
the game devs it's up to the publisher
and the publisher doesn't care about the
audience necessarily in a lot of cases
they just care about the stock market
and the shareholders and the people who
are buying stocks not the people who are
buying video games which is a nuts thing
to think about but is a reality of a
like extremely high profiting capitalist
industry the second part of that IR
Olivia who is also a friend who works in
Game Dev he's the head of a studio
called strange scaffold and he said it's
a problem of surface area and I think
this is a really good way to paint this
think about a tablecloth that's the
content and Technology of AAA game your
job is to make sure that tablecloth is
free of wrinkles now expand that
tablecloth to be the length and width of
a football field you can be the most
dedicated tablecloth smoother
redeveloper QA specialist Etc in the
entire world but you are going to miss
Sports it is impossible to have that
whole tablecloth laid football field
size and be completely smooth no matter
how hard you try simple the laser
testing budget increases do not address
that issue and that's as we kind of said
before it is almost impossible to find
every single book this is also a thing
that I've spoken about before that I I
think is
um always really Illuminating uh the
first time someone said this to me I was
like oh damn that makes so much sense
but it makes even more sense to me now
that I work in Game Dev you can have a
QA staff of 2 000 people with my webcam
there by accident sorry about that
um the minute that the game is actually
released to the public the public will
have played more hours of of that game
then your QA team like ever feasibly
could right because there are
potentially hundreds of thousands of
millions whatever of people playing the
game even for the first 60 seconds that
it is actually out they have already
played it more than your QA team ever
feasibly could have and you could say
well then hi I'm all QA people there is
no game that releases with an infinite
QA budget the game's just never going to
get made if you have that much QA stuff
so that could be players who find bugs
in 10 seconds that the QA team never
found because the amount of people
playing it especially when it comes to
PC on such different Hardware is so big
that it's just it's impossible for video
games to exist if they were to
try to scale the QA team in accordance
with the launch player base and the
bigger games get the better games get
the more intense games get the harder
that pod gets to the third question that
I asked which
um I feel like is pretty obvious but
that I have seen people talk about a lot
this year because we have so many issues
with PC ports is why do we keep having
bad PC ports specifically and really the
answer to that is that the combination
of parts that can go into any given PC
is
effectively infinite at least for a
console you have the same bits and
pieces for a PC you can swap in and out
any number of things and I love this
example that again Christina who works
in AAA Game Dev used she said did you
know that if you try and play low stock
with a Razer Viper 8khz Mouse set to 8
000 Hertz pull rate and the mouse is
plugged into an external USB hub that
the entire game freezes while the mouse
is moving at a thousand Hertz it runs
fine but at 8 000 Hertz plus the latency
of a USB hub the mouse move callback
cook in Lost Arc takes longer than 1 8
000 of a second to complete and so the
input completely flattens the game that
is such a specific issue that completely
breaks the game right I feel like that
paints a very good picture of what we're
talking about here you need to have that
particular Mouse a thousand Hertz
running at an 8 000 Hertz pull rate
plugged into an external USB in the game
Lost Ark to suggest that uh QA would
have tried this with every single Mouse
variable that may have caused this issue
that again completely flattens the game
is unreasonable so while I'm also really
torn on that by saying like you should
not be selling something that can
completely break if I use the wrong
Mouse the flip side is that how on Earth
would they have ever found that and if
this is obviously on the Very extreme
end of things and it's not really what's
happening with Jedi Survivor but I still
think it like really well illuminates
kind of the problem with porting for PC
Christina said PCS are a mess you're
creating a complex system fallbacks to
hope the game still works on an Infinite
combination of resources and I can near
guarantee what your FPS will be in every
part of every cutscene I ship to any
console I can't do the same for PC I
have seven more answers here that
effectively say the same thing there are
two quotes that I got here that are
almost word for word the same that is we
are making games that just can't be made
for all players it isn't possible
um so labia said and I love this too we
do occasionally see PC ports launching
stable form but it's few and far between
for a reason namely the stars have
aligned for a miracle again not trying
to excuse products launching this way
just trying to explain a facet of it
that I feel like I see people talk about
a lot I recognize some people don't want
the actual answers to these questions
they just want to be upset that the
product they bought is broken which is
completely valid but for those of you
who are actually curious I just wanted
to like try and give some context to
this PC ports are really hard if not
impossible according to most of these
responses that I have literally people
have used the word impossible because
PCS are just so customizable it is very
hard slash impossible to test for Every
customization option again Jedi Survivor
doesn't quite fit into that when it
looks like every customization uh will
have the same frame rate drops in the
exact same areas
um
this isn't uh oh it didn't work in this
particular section it didn't work across
the board which to me seems like an
engine problem CPU problem and an
optimization problem so I did also see a
bunch of people say that uh they the
director declined an extra delay which
is a very disingenuous way of talking
about what actually happened
um the headlines are from not very
reputable websites uh or websites that I
know to be very clickbaity and here's
what it says
when we first started having
conversations about extending the date I
was asked how much time and I said six
weeks that was exactly April 28th that's
that's no joke that's it
um but we stress tested that date you
know we looked at what else was coming
out around the same time period and we
felt like it was a really good landing
spot for us yeah so that's um
we'll answer that is
we needed a delay EA was like yeah okay
how long though and they were like six
weeks and they checked out what else was
coming around at the time that doesn't
necessarily mean that they thought the
game would be good and proper in six
weeks time no does it mean that
um EA was willing to give them more than
six weeks so the headline of refused
extra delay is a little bit disingenuous
it's more that he just said probably six
weeks he may have asked for another
delay later down the line and it didn't
happen I just wanted to cover that
because I've seen people say that I had
people say that in my twitch chat
earlier uh where that's not really what
happened so yeah a real real bummer that
this game has the performance issues
that it has especially because there are
so many things about it that I really
really like my performance has been
super solid on PS5 my performance was
very bad on PC2 even after the Patch and
I have no doubt that it will get to
a better State as they continue to test
it and frankly like have the public help
out with testing it in QA uh in many
ways it's just a real bummer that the
game launched like this right now
and it just keeps on happening and
unfortunately likely will continue to
happen I wonder if maybe video games
have gotten like unsustainably big and
that we're at a point where they are so
large and so expensive and requires so
many moving parts and so many people
um that this is just an inevitability
now games are just
too goddamn big the QA of the
programming side of the industry is just
not feasibly able to catch up with the
goddamn size of the things that we're
making anymore